[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance our son-of-a-bitch president
has in effect called a newly widowed
military wife a liar the president said
that he knew what he signed up for but
it hurts anyway my issue Johnson told
ABC and it made me cry cuz I was very
angry at the tone of his voice and how
he said it he couldn't remember my
husband's name I had a very respectful
conversation with the widow of Sergeant
Lee David Johnson and spoke his name
from beginning without hesitation Trump
responded [ __ ]
my issue Johnson has witnesses her aunt
her uncle a master sergeant the car
driver and a third term congresswoman
Frederica Wilson with a master's degree
in education all listening on
speakerphone my uncle in law was Miss
Wilson's elementary school principal
Myesha johnson explained and my husband
was in her 5,000 role-model program
that's why she's well-connected with us
she's been in our family since we were
little kids that is my issue Johnson's
witness to Donald Trump's disgusting
disrespect for this nation's flag
disrespect for its military disrespect
for its brave men whom he sent rightly
or wrongly to their deaths and worst of
all disrespect for their widows and
their orphans and their parents and who
are Trump's witnesses professional liars
based on what we know John Kelly and
Sarah Huckabee Sanders are professional
remorseless Liars for Donald Trump and
they must both resign and leave the
public stage permanently they lie for a
liar there lies contain other lies they
defend their own lies with further lies
they are liars
and they have no further credibility no
sense of civic responsibility and no
excuse for any involvement in the
governance of a free nation with this
act they have forfeited their souls in
defense of propaganda and brainwashing
and perverting freedom into
militarization they have forfeited their
loyalty to this country and replaced it
with loyalty to the demented leader of a
crazed cult they have forfeited their
humanity in the service of filth who has
now tried to directly shift the blame he
saw
richly deserves on to the crushed soul
of a newly grieving military Widow
they are indefensible in short they're
Donald Trump's kind of people a
four-star general one who approved of
torture lying about what a congresswoman
said thereby insulting the pain of the
widow who turned to that congresswoman
for support to protect the lies of a
president who had dismissed the widow's
grief followed by a press secretary a
sour and hateful individual who when
that general is caught cornered having
lied about his speech doesn't address
the truth doesn't address the reality
doesn't address her own choice to sell
her soul for an administration of
pirates chooses instead to undermine
every precept of the first 240 years of
American history by blurting out if you
want to get into a debate with a
four-star marine general I think that
that's something highly inappropriate
John Kelly is no longer a four-star
marine general he is now a four-star
liar and even if his character was as
spotless as George Washington's and it's
not he lied in public as part of his job
which is lying for Trump it is our duty
in a free country to question the
generals because every time we have not
from william Westmoreland to Alexander
Haig to Colin Powell to Michael Flynn
our country has been driven into a ditch
by the generals what is inappropriate is
to slowly incrementally almost invisibly
mesh the civilian government of the
United States with men deceitful lying
men like John Kelly and then tell the
free press of a free nation that they
must defer to those generals as if a
uniform or a medal made them more likely
to tell the truth rather than less
likely and to serve a president who now
says do not dare question the generals
but instead join me in suggesting that a
war Widow is a liar two days after her
husband's funeral when you tell the
nation that to argue with a general
annex general no less is inappropriate
you are invoking the language of
autocracy and suppression
and even military dictatorship if
getting into a debate where the general
is highly inappropriate miss Sanders you
had better tell the man for whom you
speak then he is nothing but
inappropriate Trump attacked 4-star
General John Allen Trump attacked 4-star
General Martin Dempsey Trump attacked
4-star General Colin Powell during his
campaign Trump said he knew more about
how to defeat Isis than all the generals
and during his campaign he suggested
that once in office you probably have
all new generals inappropriate
inappropriate is for this pig in the
White House to dismiss a grieving widow
to lie about it to attack the witness to
threaten the witness with so-called
proof to have to reveal the proof didn't
exist to call the widow a liar to get a
general with no remaining credibility to
lie about the witness to insist you were
better for the widows than your
predecessors when it turned out you
hadn't even contacted most of the widows
to reportedly rush deliver condolence
letters to all the widows you had
previously ignored and to have your
press secretary insist that in a
democracy it's inappropriate to question
whether the general with no further
credibility is lying when his lie was
obvious and stupid and careless and
easily disproved all of that is
inappropriate and it will not be
tolerated in this country and lurking
behind all these terrible truths is
another one just as dark just as sharp
and perhaps worse why was there such a
delay in getting to the men on the
ground at the ambush in Nazaire the men
like sergeant la David Johnson why were
they in unarmored vehicles why did it
take two days even to find the body of
Lee David Johnson why was there such a
delay in publicly acknowledging their
deaths why nearly three weeks later do
we yet have only the sketchiest picture
of what happened at this ambush why was
his widow denied any explanation of his
death
why was she as she said denied the
chance to see his body or as she also
said even to see his finger or his hand
so she could be certain it was really
him why is the FBI investigating a
military disaster 5,000 miles away from
here why are men swine like John
and Donald Trump so eager to lie and
insult and attack our right to question
authority to question force to our
generals to question lying four-star
generals why is the public discourse
focused on a congresswoman who was
invited to listen to this conversation
by Allah David Johnson's Widow instead
of being focused on why the David
Johnson died why are the professional
team of liars for Trump people like John
Kelly and Sarah Huckabee Sanders
covering up all of that is it because
Kelly and Huckabee Sanders and Trump are
also lying about Nazaire or in a free
country that is not a military
dictatorship not yet do we also not have
the right to get into a debate about
that with a lying presidential
mouthpiece and a lying X four-star
general and a goddamned lying president
resist remove peace my book based on the
first 130 of these commentaries is now
available in stores and online and I
appreciate your consideration